première saint valentin
[Musique]
entrée l'école
et mon petit amiens et fine belle déco
concernant des pétales de roses des
bougies et même l'europe a été pris par
soirée tranquille je crois que j'ai
jamais fêté la saint-valentin ouais mais
j'ai déjà rejeté la mesure allemand soit
à la peine du je fais pas des ni
des ticos assez d'accord
au matin
[Musique]
alors pour moi pour réussir une
saint-valentin faut tout simplement des
personnes qui s'aiment puis après le
reste c'est superficiel être avec la
bonne personne il sait qu'on a la bonne
personne quel que soit le lieu quel que
soit l'endroit ben on passe sa meilleure
des soirées un peu de piment
on change de l'ordinaire
avoir un bon dîner s'appelle faire et
tenez l'autre combien
faire des choses différentes des autres
jours bien que pour moi la saint
valentin c'est tous les jours
en
je pense que les mamans c'est déjà très
bien moi j'aimerais bien qu'on mérite
une lettre d'amour des cadeaux et puis
pourquoi pas
des mots doux
être là dans les moments les plus
difficiles
j'aimerais savoir être à l'écouté et
puis savoir audio bordeaux nous ait
choisis à voir ses potes pour un trajet
déjà ou autre comme ça j'en tire lui
quand je suis énervé pour ne pas me
parler çacom d'amour
faire l'effort d'une bien s'entendre
avec ma mère il ya toujours des quelques
fois des heures dans le coupe je passe
les putschs pardonner des choses c'est
pas facile pour nous
faut savoir anticiper faut savoir
écouter
et font savoir satisfaire dire je t'aime
être présent et d aller coûte et
je sais pas je pense qu'ils ont avec les
deux et la 3e d'un mot
moi c'est là bon voilà on à la personne
est le mariage
des mariages et le mans je crois
les deux chocolats
[Musique]
dîner aux chandelles chambert
les deux tête-à-tête
pour nous et pour plus haut nous
[Musique]
une toilette une soirée
mon
et 2007
[Musique]
un mot pour la fin je vais en dix ans
plaît
jeudi l'amour a parlé a toujours parlé
parlera toujours quoiqu'il arrive
[Musique]